what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here we are gonna watch
falcon and winter soldier
the star spangled man this is episode
two a couple of things really fast i'm
going out of town
this sunday so if anything big drops
while i'm gone i won't be around to
cover it and with that in mind i'm gonna
be gone for a week so
the part three will be up a little bit
late so please subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
episode three reaction
is indeed up here on the channel excuse
john after looking a little tired
it's been like three to four hours of
sleep a night including tonight because
i'm going
out of town so we're trying to try to
cover so much
for to cover a week's worth of stuff
while i'm gone but did want to give a
thank you to everyone who has followed
us over at our patreon page you can
catch the full length watch along or
re-sync up with the time code for falcon
winter soldier over there we cover so
many shows we're at the same tier you
get the option for reaction highlights
and watch along included like all these
thumbs that i'm flashing up on screen
snyder cut being one of them last thing
i think eric over at nerd chronic for
editing these reaction highlights for us
he's been helping us at it quite
a bit especially in the past couple
weeks alone so thank you so much dude
for doing that
anywho let's get to it i should have
taken eyedrops
this is going to be a body bag or
something yes
oh we're going to john walker right away
dang
okay i've been a captain before
obviously but this is different this is
captain america you'll be a symbol
captain america and that's why you feel
drama class
a different version of bucky and sam too
[Laughter]
perfect i just want to do the job
this is the job john star spangled man
with a plan and all that
it's always been in the job description
we can't just
punch you where the problems anymore
time to go to work
what a cool approach i know it's a great
i like starting off here
just with him
oh brandon good morning america
there's the shot yeah a lot of people
just
embrace him already yeah just everyone
loves you yeah
it doesn't matter team america
john walker first person in american
history to receive three medals of honor
the government to the study of your body
at mit
and you tested off the charts in every
measurable category
speed endurance intelligence here's the
thing
i got big shoes to film did you know
stephen
who the [ __ ] is this guy
that what i was doing would make people
feel safe
steve rogers was the kind of guy who
could do that he gave me hope
even though i never met him yes oh he is
not having this
so much does that look good i shouldn't
have given up the shield
oh the first scene back together
this isn't what steve wanted oh my gosh
so what do you want me to do call
america and tell them i changed my mind
you're not going to come here in your
overextended life and tell me about my
rights
it's over lucky what could be bigger
than this it's bigger than america
this guy his connections with rebel
organizations all over eastern and
central europe and he's strong
because i have a feeling they might be a
part of the big three
what victory androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no
it's not what are you fighting now
gandalf
how do you know about gandalf i read the
hobbit in 1937.
dr strange is a source no lanterns no
kryptonians
is a wizard without a hat think about it
right i'm right i just i just came up
with that bucky looks so
tired he's just sleeping
and now he's got to deal with this
this is going to be another one of those
things where like every trailer was the
first two episodes
of how pucky just is like i'm going on
the plane
i'm ready to roll to germany let's go
tell this
[Music]
all reliant on this one arm
that worked i have all of that on camera
that's like reminiscent of when bucky
fell off the train in captain america
the first adventure
but funnier
i feel like red wing's gonna start
having a real personality i see a clear
path i say we take it
we're not assassins
hey come on man i'm just messing with
you come back
we're totally assassins
little time in wakanda and you come out
white pam
i got a vibranium on i can take them and
i can fly who gives a [ __ ]
wait there's two people you only see two
oh look at that how many people you see
now wow an eighth person i think they
have a hostage
huh oh damn is this gonna be like the
highway truck chase oh
sweet oh damn already whoa
oh yeah that reminded me of civil war i
love it
they do some of the best like elevated
speed running gags
yeah for roads
vaccines no we need vaccines right now
[Music]
hey hey flag smasher
found the hostage she's not a hostage
man
[Music]
whoa
no
[Music]
oh you can't wait
oh he's he's good with the shield
absolutely he's good with it
all right we gotta start doing that
captain america
oh god
sam john captain america hell no
he grabbed it again
this is great
[Music]
[Music]
wow
oh
[Music]
[Music]
now fly him back dude
get off of me
oh i mean you got it he's he's at least
gotta handle that
good job so far
oh who's that
it's just some random car that happened
to catch up with him on the highway
i gotta get a footage of this how in the
hell after 80 years or the eighth
superstore just running loose
that didn't go as planned huh
okay
guess not i can see why bucky's actually
concerned about this thinking back to
civil war
yeah okay i think we stand a much better
chance if we all just just because you
carry that shield it doesn't mean you're
captain america
you ever jump on top of a grenade yeah
actually i have four times the
thing i do is my helmet it's a
reinforced helmet it's a long story
it's 20 miles of the airport you guys
need a ride okay so we got eight super
soldiers
this is so different than i imagined
i love it oh no we didn't drag down the
track you
you hacked my test sorry it's not
exactly hacking it's government property
kind of the government
it's not what captain america would have
said man i got mad respect for both of
y'all but you're kind of getting your
ass kicked till we showed up
who are you from battle star john spark
star stop the car
i hate this guy's name i'm not trying to
be
steve i'm not trying to replace steve
it'd be a whole lot easier
if i had caps wingmen on my side
it's always that last line
hoskins battlestar that sounds so
familiar why am i not remembering
galactica right
let's take the shield and do this
ourselves do you remember what happened
the last time we stole it
sharon was branded enemy of the state
and steve and i were on the run for two
years
[Music]
there is someone that
you should be
my therapist
i think you're right
no you're not right
just falcon kid black falcon
because i'm black and i'm the falcon
well technically
i mean yes so are you like black kid
i got it right whatever
man
how's that look at you
we uh met at 51. if i met you mean
i whupped your ass then
yeah i took half that metal arm in that
fighting goiang
but i see he's managed to grow it back
isaiah the reason we're here it's
because there's more of you and me out
there
you and me and we need to know how i'm
not
oh interesting they put my ass
in jail for 30 years
coming into my cell even your people
weren't done with me
i said get out of my house
let's go let's go steve didn't know
about him he didn't i didn't tell him
so you're telling me that there was a
black super soldier decades ago and
nobody knew about it
damn is there a problem here no we just
talked we're fine
i see your id
wow i didn't recognize you without the
oh
god oh cringe
no this guy black is this guy black
jesus
there's a warrant out for your arrest
the president pardoned him for all that
i missed your court mandated therapy
it's like missing a check-in with your
p.o sorry mr barnes you're under arrest
[Music]
i love how [ __ ] polite they were to
him yeah
like oh damn we didn't even real great
we get a two-for-one stop
so who wants to go first
it's time for the soul gazing exercise i
like this one though
thank you i love this
[Music]
all right good we're locked in it's a
little closer
wait what are you doing are you having a
staring [ __ ]
why'd you give up that shield why are
you making such a big deal out of
something that has
nothing to do with you steve believed in
you
gave you that shield and you threw it
away like it was nothing so maybe he was
wrong about you and if he was wrong
about you then he was wrong about me
maybe this is something you or steve
will never understand
but can you accept that i did what i
thought was right
i'll see you outside
thank you that was
really great
hey no it started a dialogue yeah
well i feel better i feel awful
is this guy bothering you you're under
arrest your hair's black
it's ridiculous look
if we divide ourselves we don't stand a
chance you guys
know that but you guys have rules of
engagement and all kind of
authorizations you have to get
we're free agents we're more flexible a
word of advice then
stay the hell out of my way
there's that sinister set there's the
villain i was captain of the football
team
[Laughter]
i wanted always to come back to that
next time he sees bucky gonna shove him
in a locker
walker doesn't have any leads i know
where you're going with this and no he
knows
all of hydra's secrets don't you
remember siberia so you're just gonna go
sit in a room with this guy
we're gonna go see zemo
[Music]
i could cue that classical music
oh damn zemo was coming back because he
looked away
and then he got blood back and it's like
oh damn [ __ ] i'm still in the person
she still kept my door locked like
another
no i can't live
all right i believe the isaiah guy
was like at one point in marvel comics i
believe he's in reference to
the person who was once touted as like
the black captain america i don't know
much about him i
remember learning about him though so
i'm pretty sure
that's who he is but battle star that's
the one that i'm like
what is that that's one that's racking
my brain that's one i want to look up
battle star marvel let's see here yes
okay he became the fifth character to
assume the alias
bucky before taking on the name battle
star
he really yes he really is oh yeah
what i think sean walker's the comment
that i made
like it's a bucky and sam okay all right
i knew something sounded
incredibly familiar about him and isaiah
yeah i think okay let's just do one
google search
yep okay yeah yeah yeah that's the one
all confirmed that's
what i was right about awesome um anywho
leave the
easter eggs to the professionals like
canadian lad and new rock stars
mephisto cosmic wonder blah blah blah
leave it to them
yeah i want to talk about this just from
storytelling standpoint and
you know forgive me if i'm getting some
facts wrong like i mentioned the top of
this video
three to four hours of sleep all week a
little bit tired
but i still really enjoyed this episode
it's an interesting weird
like thing that we do here with the
channel because so much what we do is
like we consume a lot of content and we
talk about and we give our
thoughts and opinions and reveal our
emotions on the matter and it's
strange to be like oh man it's 12 30 at
night we have to film this
i'm so tired and then to be so wrapped
up in something that i'm like
i'm awake that's it yeah and that's but
to me i'm using i'm saying that it's
like that's an indicator
of how compelling this is because prior
to filming we really pass out you know
yeah and suddenly i'm like i'm really
awake like that's the power of a
well-told story and a compelling story
yeah it makes you forget about yourself
and it just pulls you in and it brings
you that joy of like yeah i was just
swept up in the joy of watching it at
least during the reaction portion i
wasn't even thinking
i about it like please keep it coming
please i'm so enjoying this
like the action was incredible the
action was reminding me a lot of like
the sequences in winter soldier and
and in uh civil war like the the chase
on the road the sideline thought i got
to give credit to
the marketing team here yes because wow
they hide a lot of what went on in that
fight
i thought it was only flag smashers and
bucky and sam
yeah all that stuff with walker showing
up and uh
oh what's his name i'm just gonna call
him battlestar and battlestar showing up
as well i love them coming into here and
i think they're making such a great
argument
i know like with shows like one division
and all that and i'm sure there's people
who are doing it here
who are going to be doing all their
theories and all that but
literally right now what i want to do is
focus just on the compelling cases that
they make
starting off with john walker i thought
it was so powerful
how they put you into his perspective at
the top of this show
you know and prior to this episode i'm
like no those guys are going to be a
bad guy and there's still remnants here
where you're like he's
john walker you don't trust john walker
he does the captain america way you're
not supposed to be
captain america okay you don't trust us
agent john walker
and then when you're in his perspective
in the beginning
i love how with wyatt russell's
performance you're like
seeing him in such a vulnerable lonely
moment with this woman
um are they dating they do that that
pinky uh they do that pinky problem
it's a familial thing so i i took it as
this
or something or something oh so it is
his girlfriend or wife
his wife she's his wife
my point is from the last episode when
you're seeing it from the way the world
is
showing us in the media and from bucky
and sam
when you're looking at it through their
perspective it's like you just see him
as this cocky [ __ ] he's taking up the
shield and thinks he's entitled to it
you know
and then when you cut to him here you're
seeing him in a very vulnerable spot
and he's nervous and he's trying his
best to be like i just want to do like
the missions and the job i don't want to
do the media stuff
but he really is trying his best like he
seems sincere in that
he's not just some guy who's like
that's how i i was i i didn't i had no
idea how he would be
that's the power of that image at the
end of the first episode is you see him
step up and he gives that little wink
and that they did design i think the
helmet for him to make him look like
kind of a kid in a costume so
yeah there is this sort of element where
the second they introduce him you
already have
all these thoughts about him from the
last episode yeah because when he
is in like being all vulnerable there
you're seeing like this is
john walker and then when he goes to the
football stadium
he's got his bruce campbell thing going
on as i call it i mean
it's bruce campbell thing and kurt
russell thing are not too far off yeah
there's a reason they could play like
handy badass
yeah but yeah like he was doing the
interviews he's got like the charm and
the machismo and the
a little bit of a different cadence with
his voice
and he's got that sense of humor yeah
yeah eagles follow me everywhere yeah
you know
prior to that you see that he's he is
like that nervous guy
in the locker room being back there in
the in the like before a football game
you know
i think what they're doing with him is
really
well constructed because i find myself
as an
audience member going no i don't think
you should be
captain america i don't think you need
to be captain america i don't think you
get really who captain america
truly was just by the fact of how
government-oriented you are
that's not captain america
captain big government but what i think
what the series has done so well is
show you that he cares that he is
sincere in the fact that he's dedicated
to
being the best he can be and then i love
that when you do get the action scenes
with him um on that chase of you're like
well you know he's
pretty good with the shield and he knows
what we're doing when they showed that
training montage of him just hit targets
with it i was like wow
even for like for a guy with purportedly
no super strength or super soldier serum
or anything
like it looks like that thing could rip
your arm off so you got it
yeah no you're 100 right about that yeah
yeah john walker
i think excellently portrayed here and i
think wyatt russell's like uh
he's he's compelling to watch he's a
terrific actor i mean they really
show you john walker from so many angles
because yeah you get that personal angle
of just him on his own and then you
immediately cut to him
doing the thing he was nervous about but
then you see like oh i get why
the government chose this guy because he
does know how to turn on the charisma
when it counts
then you see him out in the field like
when they happen in on bucky and sam and
then you see them
further you know at the whatever that
facility is where they meet with the
therapist and it's like each time
you see him there's a little bit of a
different shade that you're getting
depending on who else is around what the
situation is and so even though there's
a lot of stuff going on and we are
following bucky and sam for most of it i
thought that
every time john walker showed up they
revealed a little more about him and i
got really conflicted because i'm like
he's charming and i
i kind of like him but i don't want him
to become you know who i'm
pretty sure he'll probably become and
now what i'm sitting here wondering
about him is
how nuanced and how difficult is that
gonna be and i have a feeling that i'll
probably still be torn you know
with the way they handle it going
forward which is good yeah i think
though
they still have the layer of ego there
like he wants to work with sam and bucky
but
he still wants to be the leader yeah he
wants to take the initiative and he
wants to ingratiate himself with them by
doing favors nobody else yeah yeah man i
think they've done a really good job
flashing them out and of course with
like bucky and sam
finally getting a chance to team up like
they really have brought that buddy cop
dynamic to life
i think that's really well executed like
their chemistry together here
is so good you know there was something
about that therapy scene that i actually
thought would just be funny
you know i was once in i've done a
couple of like they said they were
acting classes but they really aren't i
forget what the classes are called there
was mainly this exercise of repetition
where
it's kind of like a therapy thing where
you're just one-on-one with an
individual but you're in front of a
group of people you have to make eye
contact and you have to
kind of have a thing like that but it's
more public and vulnerable watching that
scene when they went from humor
into like a real conversation their
conversation of being like i
of like zambian like can can you just
try to accept the fact that i thought it
was doing the right thing
that's kind of what they're all doing
here you know like this this is doing
such a good job
of exploring intent and perspectives
in such a way that feels so richly
nuanced you know like
i find myself in a gray area to everyone
here
from john walker to the flag smashers
like there's no one here who just
seems like a hundred percent no you know
everyone has some layer where i'm like
i'm not a hundred percent yes and i'm
not 100
no and i think that just makes for a
more rich
compelling drama it's not just gonna be
like they're going to go their separate
ways
i think that at least started the
dialogue maybe that moment in time of
that conversation ends with them
having it like all right when it's done
we go our separate ways but
they did start the open vulnerable
conversation
the amount of time they're going to have
to spend together on the road and
uncovering
truths and past and having to understand
one another you know they're going to
get that vulnerable
[ __ ] going beyond the humor so i thought
it was great that they mixed that in
uh in a way that felt very natural along
with just frequently
checking in with what's it actually like
to be an avenger how does this actually
affect your life in
regular situations like when the cops
show up and you're not in uniform
yeah they don't recognize you yet both
this and the previous episode have had
layers of that and this one even had a
little bit for
bucky to have to tangle with and so that
seems like another thread that they're
really going to keep developing
throughout the show
i mean that's a very i've heard of like
i've heard many black celebrities talk
about that
of how they're not recognized and they
get treated
like this is this guy bothering you yeah
they get pulled over for
unfair reasons or they get patted down
you know they get arrested
until like but if you're recognized like
you're a celebrity then they're like all
right you're writing my book you know
i get an autograph yeah it's neat to see
it the show
willing to go there with falcon in
particular you know
i like that nugget of a moment of
like that line that he has is good
writing black falcon or just call me
black falcon because i'm black or are
you black kid you know like those are
that's it's true you know that's
the way some people operate the way some
people will think in terms of just
because of the color of his skin well
let's see how
like when you're a minority because
there's even that jab about bucky being
the white panther or whatever because
he's
the like one white guy in wakanda hiding
out yeah it's nice to bring that back
around too because i was infinity war
and the infinity war where he called
them black panther to call him white
wolf
yeah it was nice to get that knob he got
some like your nods here and there
you know you've been talking about have
you ever jumped on a grenade references
back to first avenger it's a bunch of
little nods here and there
you know you find it funny how they're
treating their audience with respect to
the point where they're like
weirdly they're not like recapping [ __ ]
because i had to
from a tired brain i had to re jog my
memory
uh really quick be like oh yeah that's
right uh in civil war they talked about
the other soldiers so when
uh they go to meet up with zemo before
iron man and captain america
and bucky all fight with each other
they're in the impression like there's
other winter soldiers there
and then they show up and they're all
shot and the zemo just planted them
there but zemo clearly knows about the
other super soldiers and knows about the
super soldier past
and has all the secrets to hydra so
having that kind of
eerie chilling line where in civil war
you think bucky's the last one
because you when they they went that was
siberia
right i think if i'm wrong screw it
right i got the name of the country
i named the country wrong last episode
you can do it things just happen
sometimes right
when civil war ended it's like oh no
bucky is the last remaining
super soldier from when hydra was doing
stuff and then you can see how that's
such a
personal eerie thing for bucky to
uncover and to have kept the secret of
isaiah
and the fact of how isaiah was a hero
yet they just treated him like
an experiment that was heartbreaking
that was heartbreaking like
and it was like even though it is
fantastical of the circumstances it's
like
totally plausible from a human
perspective when you think of it
especially
yeah especially from the time the era
that he was from you know yeah
like from the comics relation the most i
really know about
isaiah the black captain america is
pretty much that
and so to see how much gravitas was
brought to that moment
you could feel the pain in the history
like i i love the way they capture that
how he shows up and they said isaiah but
i'm like how does he the super soldier
one you know is he the
it's isaiah washington yeah cameoing is
yourself
you know i mean he shows up and he's
talking like a vet
from like the 50s or something like that
i think it was 51 they said they met
when they're talking with each other the
way it's directed i think is great
because they really
treat him like a war vet and then the
reveal
of when he throws that thing against the
wall and it just gets
latching in there like damn he's old we
still got the super soldier strength
yeah still rip you in half and then
that's the revealed additional layer of
oh damn they had a hero back then they
had a super soldier
and then instead of letting him be like
when captain america existed
when he was you know the first avenger
that when he first came into play it was
like captain america steve rogers look
at this gloria let's put him
let's have him do shows yeah let's have
him do shows and stuff you get someone
like isaiah and he just gets lost in the
shadows and just gets experimented on
yeah
and i think that's a that's like a
powerful commentary to have here
yeah well i mean it goes to show you
that especially in the world of heroes
it's not
just about the strength that you have
the power bestowed upon you and it's
also got to do with the people around
you what they ascribe to you in terms of
belief and worth and you know if there
are enough of these people around you
don't believe in you and don't think
you're actually worth anything
it doesn't matter how much power you
have they can just you know take you
away
imprison you and experiment on you the
flag smashers you know
i think there's more to uncover there oh
yeah obviously you know like
i still feel like we don't know enough
but clearly
one thing that i really felt i got from
this you know
it's one thing to just be like the a
great villain believes
they're in the right you know like like
thanos he really believes he's in the
right what i love about their portrayal
and their more
intimate moments is better than the way
the music's going in some like
certain ominous shots for the most part
the way the actors are all playing
and the way even the dialogue you're
like i i feel like these guys are just
like the good rebels
like a little ragtag group that's on the
run when they're not actually throwing
yeah in a fight or something like that
and then yeah again you see the shift in
perspective of like they're desperate we
gotta move now you know you can't even
lay down for the night
but they seem like they really think
they're doing the the right thing like
they really believe it
you know yeah and then when they're like
they think they're doing something good
yeah and then when like all the suits
show up to try and take them down like
they do
have a certain ominous quality even to
them
showing yeah so you have this clash of
two kind of harsh
forces because we have the mistrust of
the the government in general
sure ready and then we have you know
just the menace of the flag smashers
again it's another one of those nuanced
things where the destruction they're
causing are you arguably
pretty bad for people in general but at
the same time their ideology is
kind of fascinating you know i think
what this episode did a wonderful job of
doing is like how i started
talking about dealing with a variety of
perspectives
it's like when you're with bucky and sam
when they're with john walker in them
you're like
these guys are stupid
when a scene is captured from their
perspective you're like man they they
just seem like they might be good dudes
and they're just trying to do the right
thing you know
yeah again if you didn't have the
baggage of like well we know who john
walker is probably gonna turn up to be
then you could even stand back from it
and go well you know maybe if sam and
bucky were just
a little more open to it they could all
get longer i'd be fine you know well
this is good [ __ ] i really like this uh
a lot love this one i love this one and
uh yeah the big takeaways were the
deeper things it was fun
it was funny it was surprising i was
moved a lot yeah a great episode
and really well assembled too like some
very interesting avengers assemble
oh easter eggs
john we got to get up in a few hours oh
that's right
we're gonna be late to that i just know
it anywho we gotta do some slicing and
dicing here
erica that's the highlights one of us
does the thumbs one of us does the
freaking editing this discussion one of
us does the watch a lot for patreon
so yeah you know got three people
working together fully finish this
project
off we got to get to it thank you so
much for being here
subscribe click the notification bell
see you guys